Speaker 1: So I don't know how many of you
remember it was a really big day in my life,
but it may not have been in your life.
About a month ago, I did a breakdown of
Rick Scott's eleven point plan to save
America. And this was it was notable because
it sort of seemed like in a sea of cultural
issues and talking points that make no sense.
A Republican was actually putting together a
policy proposal, and this is the Republican
Florida Senator Rick Scott. So we looked at it.
The proposal was absolutely absurd. Incredibly,
if Rick Scott got his way, the policies he
proposes would be incredibly damaging to
the country. A lot of them weren't even really
policies. They were just again cultural issues
masked as policy. But we reviewed it because it
was actually something apparently substantive
from Republicans, and it was a crazy and
disastrous proposal. Rick Scott went on Fox News
and on. Fox News reporter John Roberts calls out
Rick Scott for some of the things in his plan. And
it's not, you know that John Roberts is the
be all end all of journalism or whatever.
But here he did a good job of saying,
here's stuff that's in your proposal.
Rick Scott tries to call them Democratic talking
points, and John Roberts is like, No, no, no,
it's straight out of your proposal. And it is.
And Rick Scott doesn't know what way you know
what is up, what is down. It doesn't make any
sense. This is how flaccid these proposals are,
where as soon as they are questioned about them,
they say, Well, those are just democratic spin.
No, it's in your proposal. Check this out.
Speaker 3: Because Putin is such a
thug, a murderous thug.
Speaker 2: All right. Let's
switch to politics now because there's a lot
that we've got to look forward to between now
and November the 8th. You recently put out an 11
point plan to rescue America. Right? Two of the
big points of which are quote All Americans should
pay some income tax to have skin in the game,
even if a small amount currently over half of
Americans pay no income tax. It also says all
federal legislation sunsets in five years. If a
law is worth keeping, Congress can pass it again,
so that would raise taxes on half of Americans
and potentially sunset programs like Medicare,
Medicaid and Social Security. Why would you
propose something like that in an election year?
Speaker 3: Sure. And that's of
course, the Democrat talking points.
Speaker 2: It's also a two year plan.
Speaker 3: It's here's hearsay. But here's the
thing about reality for a second. So let's talk
Speaker 2: about Senator, but Senator Charles,
so it's not a Democratic
talking point. It's in the plan
Speaker 3: and also in the plan.
Speaker 1: OK, so now notice how he
first said it's it's a lie. And then when he can't
say anything other than. Well, yeah, it is in the
plan, he says. But there's also other things
in the plan now. What John Roberts is saying
is is true. When Rick Scott says everyone should
pay at least some federal income tax. You have
to remember there are lots of people that end up
paying no federal income tax because between a low
income and the standard deduction and child
tax credits and whatever you end up paying
zero federal income tax. Now we have to remember
these folks pay a lot of other taxes. They pay
sales taxes, they pay excise taxes. If they have
a vehicle, they have car registration fees, they
may pay state taxes. It's not that they don't pay
taxes. This is a popular right wing talking point
to say the rich are paying so much and half the
country pays no taxes. Well, OK, you're entitled
to child tax credits and the standard deduction,
et cetera. But it is part of their talking point
as to why the tax system needs to be changed. Rick
Scott is then confronted. Well, that is going to
increase taxes for half of Americans, per your
own favorite talking points. And Rick Scott says,
Well, that's that's democratic propaganda. No,
it's actually in your plan. Then he switches to,
well, here's other stuff that's also in my plan
Speaker 3: says we audit every year. Talk about
exactly how we're going to fix Medicare and Social
Security. Here's what's happening. No one that I
know of wants to sunset Medicare, Social Security.
But what we're doing is we don't even talk about
it. Medicare goes bankrupt in four years. Social
Security goes bankrupt in 12 years. I think we all
Speaker 1: remember that they've been using these
bankruptcy talking points for a long time, and
they're all completely untrue.
Speaker 3: To figure out how we
preserve those programs, every program
that we care about, we ought to state,
stop and take the time to preserve those programs.
Speaker 1: Now understand what he's saying here.
He claims, I don't want to get rid of Social
Security and Medicare. No, I don't want to
do that, but I do want us to debate whether
to keep them on a regular. A basis, so let's
rephrase what he's saying, he's saying, I
want it to be on the table that we might
gut or eliminate Social Security and or Medicare,
that he wants that possibility at least.
Speaker 3: I mean, I just fought the postal bill
because it put more responsibility on Medicare and
took it off the Postal Service and put Medicare
in a worse position. Now let's go back. Let's
talk about taxes for a second. I'll put my record
up against anybody on tax cuts I tax. I cut taxes
and fees a hundred times as governor, but
Speaker 1: I understand that that's such a
meaning. I don't even want to waste time on this,
but this is how politicians lie where he goes.
Well, listen. When I was governor, I cut taxes
and fees a hundred times. You guys understand
that that can mean OK. He's cutting the vehicle
registration fee from 50 to $45. That's one cut.
He is changing the excise tax rate from one point
five percent to one point three percent. That's
a second cut. These are sort of meaningless
statements, and politicians are so good at
just offhandedly mentioning them. Here's what's
Speaker 3: unfair. We have people that don't
that could go to work and have figured out how to
have government pay their way. That's not right.
Speaker 1: So that's actually what this is
about. That's actually what it's about. It's
about cutting welfare and all sorts of different
programs. So understand that the Republican,
there's some people who say Republicans
want to kill Americans by putting people in
genocide camps or whatever. And then some
Republicans say it's Democrats who want to put
people in genocide or concentration camps
or whatever. And now the way it works is
Republicans want to slowly chip away at programs
that enable people to live in a dignified way
and take away the ability of folks to afford
unexpected, costly events or just the cost of
being alive. And this is the way they do it.
Listen, we we should look at whether Medicare
really makes sense to keep. We should justify
whether Social Security should keep going.
We should look at food stamps. We should make
sure that everybody's paying some federal tax,
which means the poor make the poor pay more
in taxes. That's how you do it. It's not,
you know, these these 1984 ask FEMA camps or
whatever else. It's these little little cuts
to take away people's dignity. And I don't know
how much the Fox audience realizes the dishonesty
and the absurd nature of what Rick Scott is
proposing and his complete inability to defend
it here. But the best way to dismantle all of
these so-called plans is you go line by line
and explain to them this is what it would do.
How do you justify it half the time? They'll say,
that's not really what's in my plan?
And then you go, No, it is. Here it is.
And then the other half, they'll just explain it
away with very transparently bogus talking points.